[Music]
zach is in las vegas hey zach welcome to
the ramsay show
hey thanks dude god bless
god bless you sir what's up
better than i deserve how can i
yeah so the my
easy
straightforward question is
should i continue to fax out my 401k
should i
not do that and use the disposable
income to save for down payment for a
home which i kind of already have almost
or dedicate 100
of all of my earned income to paying off
my debt
so
the context is
i'm 37 years old uh my salary employed
salary is 75 000. i have 26 000 in
credit card debt
13 000 of that debt is 0 until may 2022
and 7 500 of it is 0
until
november of 2022.
i have a 420 25 a month car payment but
that's zero percent
i'm renting
um
and that's about it
how much do you have in savings
about eight thousand eight thousand
and how much do you owe on your car
23 give or take okay 23 000 okay
all right
well lucas here's the thing
maxing out your 401k being debt free and
buying a house are all three
excellent goals
but you know how you eat an elephant you
know how you eat an elephant a bite at a
time
if you try to do three things at once
none of them are gonna get done
so years ago doing what i do i started
coaching people and i started doing
myself
to say i've got to focus
all of my efforts on one thing and then
the next thing and then the next thing
and that focus allowed me to actually
accomplish the goals rather than dilute
my efforts by
spreading them so thin that nothing got
done
and we call that process that now
millions of families have gone through
the baby steps
sure baby step one
is a thousand dollars
baby step two is to become debt free
everything but the house
three is save an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses
after you have that done is when you
would save the down payment for a house
and then you would start baby step four
which is 15 of your income going into
retirement
you sir have a major debt mess
and because it's all zero percent you
think it's intelligent it's not you have
made a mess
you owe 50 000
on crap
and you don't even know what all of it
is
but you're all walking around like it's
zero percent and that doesn't matter a
bit you have a mess
so what you've got to do is take seven
of your eight thousand dollars apply it
to your smallest seven thousand dollars
worth of credit cards because those will
be your smallest debts
list all of your debts smallest to
largest pay minimum payments on
everything but the little one attack the
little one with a vengeance work your
way through these debts as fast as you
can probably going to take you 18 months
to two years and then you're gonna build
your emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses so if you had twenty
thousand dollars setting in a bank
account and no payments at all and
started saving for your house down
payment you would be wise
sure yeah i've already in the past
since april of 2019
i've paid off 26 000.
and i mean i you know i do i did take
your your course way back my parents
kind of put me through it and uh you
know i was zero credit card debt i had
zero debt period you know like 800
credits for everything but i was in my
late 20s and you know i was looking
around at my elders
who
you know
it had good 401ks and great money but
they worked at a company for 20 years so
when i had relatively zero
responsibilities i
you know did the risky thing and went
and pursued my dreams and
and i'll never regret it because you
know god definitely built my character
as a man that's the man i am today but
now i do have this mess and so
i i know that the debt snowball but
i guess i kind of wanted
just a little bit more feedback on your
your perspective uh regarding
it sounded like you wanted to be an
exception
that you're a special guy
that your debt was a little bit
different because it was zero percent
and you have the harder idea
that didn't make you a man yeah
yeah no no that's that you know but it's
it's more of like so if i'm maxing out
my 401k my
as i am now like i'm i'm putting 25 of
my paycheck in
and
my discretionary income after my
expenses every month is 600.
and so i have that to play with if i
stop contributing to my 401k except for
four percent which is the company match
what do you do for a living
i'm an architectural photographer okay
is that zach you're you're broke and
deeply in debt yeah you're broke brother
this is what your plan brought you to
and so i wouldn't use your plan anymore
your plan sucks yeah you're broke man
you need a new plan and our plan is
proven and it works you can choose you
get to do that you're 37 and you're a
man you can decide what you want to do
um but you called here to ask what we
would tell you to do
and um
the law of gravity is the law of gravity
find a proven
process
and attach yourself to it it's called in
business best practices
we find out something that's working and
we emulate it copy it steal the idea
whatever you want to call it and i want
you to steal these ideas i want you to
work as baby steps exactly
as you were taught in financial peace
university
and um
and you know if you want to do something
else that's fine but you called here
yeah and i want to
press on him a second he was trying to
make this a math problem
and i think one of the fundamental
misses sometimes it is ultimately a math
problem
is that it's a psychology issue too and
there should be some discomfort i want
you to get out of this thing
and it's like well it's a hundred
dollars here and we can then you wake up
and you're 37 and you're making a great
salary and you have negative nothing to
show for it right there's a lot of
photographers who don't make 75 000 you
must be good at what he does
but he can't see the forest for the
trees here man yeah you're trying to
here's the thing
you can't fix stupid with math
and personal finance is 80 behavior
it's only 20 percent head knowledge the
stuff that make people the principles
and the processes that makes people
wealthy are very simple to understand
but they involve controlling yourself we
just heard in the last debt free screen
paying off that smallest one gave us
some momentum to get the next one they
gave us a yeah it's about setting your
insides on fire and i think you said it
like brother you're you're broke
you're broke you owe 50 000
man
and you make 75. i mean that's not a
good ratio no
that should scare you yeah instead of
going well it's zero percent and seventy
five hundred zero percent seventy four
may have twenty two shut up you're broke
and if an architect firm is going to
have to do layoffs
before they start cutting the principal
architects they're going to cut the
full salary photographer that makes 25
grand
the security you think you have isn't so
secure brother
be debt free man yeah yeah it's it's
it's worth it so but this is a
decision-making process that people have
to go through and
and so um
you know it's
years ago i hired a trainer to come to
my house and you know try to get the
belly off of me again and try to try to
do something try to get myself in shape
and um
and it would be like i go down there
i've got a keg he's got a six-pack
right and he goes well this is what you
need to do
and i go well you know i kind of think i
have this other plan
[Music]
and he goes he
sits your butt in the floor and do sit
up shut up
okay so i can see your body but
but listen i have this other idea
i mean you know it's like yeah you're
gonna have to quit eating 73 doughnuts
yeah well i think i can do the donuts as
long as i do the workout how about you
slow down trainer
and then i found the you know the whole
thing is nutrition's almost the whole
stinking thing you cannot run a big mac
you cannot run enough miles
that's right that's right my gosh
decide who you're gonna listen to uh the
guy with the keg or the guy with a
six-pack